hello today myself and my colleagues
postal workers throughout the country
will be taking industrial reaction
unfortunately something that I don't
want to do nor the rest of my colleagues
we want to be working for you we want to
be your postings on your doorstep but we
have an employer who is hell-bent on
destroying our terms and conditions and
also the Postal Service that we all know
and love please support us we want to be
here next year like we have been for the
last 500 years
and Sam Smith owns pot gang it's an
online business selling grow your own
vegetable and Herb kits and his business
has taken a financial hit from the
strikes we usually use Royal Mail for
our monthly deliveries is there a
reliable and affordable delivery options
for boxes of our size and weight but to
be honest with these strikes happening
our Focus has been on the implications
for our our own Christmas deliveries our
priorities are ensuring that customers
and potential customers get their boxes
in the time expects for a for a price
that's that's fair so over the stroke
periods we're actually taking a bit of a
financial hit ourselves and switching
everyone over to a more expensive but
more reliable delivery for Royal Mail if
they're their pricing and services
affected by the outcome of these strikes
we'll have to weigh out whether they're
the best delivery partner for us as we
need to protect our own profits in order
to pay our own staff
well Sandy best and Sam Smith join us
now live uh Sandy you're on the picket
line in Parliament Square I know you
sounded very regretful that it's come to
this is it just about pay for you or is
it bigger than that
it's much bigger than that it's about
our terms and conditions but as I said
in the video
[Applause]
the Royal Mail the Royal Mail as we will
know it will not be in existence if the
people that are in charge of this
company get their way they want us to
get rid of us they want to employ only
drivers on less money and more hours and
we just cannot allow that to happen we
were the people that people depended
upon in the pandemic we were that face
that everybody saw we carried on working
through it and now that we're rewarded
basically with you can go out the door
and we don't want you and we don't want
that for our customers either and that
includes our business customers too we
don't want to be here today we want to
be out delivering to our customers but
we've this is the final thing that we
have to be able to have to do because no
there's no choice in what they're doing
to us
let's go to Sam on that and strength of
feeling has driven thousands of people
from all over the country Swindon uh in
Sandy's case there have you any sympathy
can you can you see their point of view
when you're trying to run a small
business
uh yeah I mean of course I I understand
in a their own priorities and and got to
got to protect what lay thinks important
to them
um I guess my concern really is much
more about our own customers and just
making sure that we can adapt and
provide the level of service that we
have committed ourselves
um so getting our boxes to people
um on time ahead of Christmas
um and a price that's reasonable
um so for me it's much less about
um the actual Stripes themselves it's
much more about how we can adapt to to
make sure that no one there's no dip in
our own service and Sam you you've been
having to enlist uh courier companies
which is I guess going to affect your
bottom line
yeah yeah massively I mean one of the
one of the reasons that we we go we go
with Royal Mail usually is because for
the the size and weight of box that we
send
um they're a very reasonable price
um and are pretty reliable too
um but at the moment we're having to
shift everyone over to the likes of dpd
or UPS who are more expensive for us
um but to be honest
um that they are slightly delayed as
well at the moment due to the extra
demand they have due to Royal Mail
strikes but it's much less hassle for us
and we're able to deliver roughly the
sort of delivery times we've already
committed to our our customers through
them but yeah we're having to pay you
know an extra couple quid per delivery
which
um puts puts some Financial pressure on
on us too yeah and Sandy let's go back
to you I mean your foregoing pay uh by
by going on strike it's it's not a
climate where many people can afford to
forego pay and Royal Mail will say that
they have made an offer and it appears
on the surface of it that it's an offer
that's far more generous than any other
groups of striking workers have managed
to achieve is it not better to just
accept it
um the offer that they've given us is
two percent imposed this year one and a
half percent next year and on top of
that the other percentage which goes
apparently up to nine percent will all
be on condition that we we sign away our
terms and conditions for me personally
and for my husband who is also he's done
43 years I've done 33 years and our son
is a post years now as well for both of
us that will mean a 40 pound a week pay
cut
if I get five pound a week given to me
and 40 pound a week taking off I make
that 35 pound a week I'm worse off I
don't think there's many people in this
country that would sign away that there
might not sound a lot of money to some
people but on the basic wages of postee
40 pound a week is almost a day's pay
and the Royal Mail will say Sandy that
uh striking really hits their bottom
line and by doing so you're making any
potential payoffer unaffordable for them
what do you say to that
I say to that that we made 758 million
pounds and I say we we the posties made
that money and there are our CEO Simon
Thompson has given away 500 million
pounds of shares and awarded himself and
his other board members Big Fat Cat
salaries and on top of that bonuses and
shares themselves he's now saying we're
losing a million pounds a day I would
call for that call that gross
mismanagement of a company because at
the end of the day you shouldn't be able
to go for one month six months to making
millions of pounds of profit to losing
the million pounds a day and it's for
him to answer those questions and for
him to resign
let's go back to you Sam how
understanding are your customers about
the fact that they'll have to make their
orders earlier than they would normally
have to and they might have to wait an
unspecified period for things to arrive
um I've got to be honest with you in the
in the build up to Christmas people
aren't particularly understanding
um you know their priority is getting
the presence they've ordered on in the
timeline that they they anticipated when
ordering them
um so so yeah I mean one of the main
reasons that we're shifting away from
Royal Mail through this period is to
avoid the the customer service headache
and time drain that will cause us
um you know we're just a few people sat
here doing this sending veg growing kits
out to people
um but and people aren't that don't
really often don't really talk to you
like you're a person
um when they're stressed about about
getting their their things in time and
so it's not really worth the impact
it'll have on us and we just we just
want to make sure that Chris Christmas
goes as smoothly as possible for us
yeah and how confident are you that you
can get everything out uh in time for
Christmas I guess you just don't know
yeah no I'm very confident that we'll do
it we just have to adapt and make
alternative plans to to avoid the impact
of the strikes you know we'll use
queries that are more reliable through
this period
um and find other ways to to deliver our
service in in time
um you know we just need to be nimble on
our feet and and respond and find ways
to to sustain our quality
all right and final word from you Sandy
I know you said you have sympathy for
small business owners like like Sam
there have you any hope that these
negotiations are going to see a
breakthrough
what we need is we need Mr Thompson to
stop spending most of his time on social
media uh dumbing down his employees and
actually concentrate on actually talking
to the CWU and also we also need big
businesses and little businesses to put
pressure on Raw Mel so that they will
take these negotiations seriously and
also we've asked government and
intervention as well which has been
turned down because we've got somebody
who's in a different country basically
firing up all the shares and taking over
and wanting just to make it the parcel
company if we continue as we are we will
not be the Royal Mail that you know and
love we will just be another parcel
company the same as every other one that
throws your packets up against the door
instead of that friendly face that you
can speak to somebody that you know
thank you